les premières fleurs sont de sortie les
jardins se partent de couleur à valencer
le printemps s'installe l'occasion de se
réinventer c'est le travail de Colette
Cassin conseillère artistique appelé par
le château pour revégétaliser le jardin
de la princesse j'ai souhaité faire deux
jardins Renaissance
Renaissance italienne qui allait bien
avec la majesté du château donc bordée
de lavande et devant il y a des rosiers
qui vont aussi
décorer le socle des statues qui n'est
pas très esthétiques Colette Cassin
avait déjà été appelé l'année dernière
pour créer les partères de la grande
perspective des bordures de vivaces qui
invitent à la promenade si vous voulez
que les gens voient les plantes
approchent touchent par exemple à cette
oreille d'ours là il faut les voir de
près et également il y a des parfums les
sons aujourd'hui parfum du parfum donc
faut les voir de près à l'intérieur
aussi il y a de la nouveauté le château
a retrouvé une partie de son mobilier
historique grâce à un dépôt de la Banque
de France il y a deux meubles ici c'est
la commode à double battant et le bureau
qui est ici du bureau de ministre et qui
donc est réputé avoir appartenu à talent
dans le salon de musique 6 chaises à dos
de lire sont à nouveau exposées au
château ça fait un bel ensemble
absolument absolument somptueux et ça
fait plaisir aussi de retrouver je
dirais un lustre complémentaire pour
cette ce salon incroyable
ces meubles vendus par le château en
1925 sont à nouveau visibles du public
depuis quelques jours le jardin de la
princesse devrait être présenté au
public dans son nouvel écrin d'ici le
début de l'été